mesdames messieurs bon dimanche
l'abandon du projet de troisième lien a
pris beaucoup de place la semaine
dernière éclipsant les consultations
parlementaires sur le projet de loi 15
qui encadre l'imposant très forme de la
santé de Christian Dubé un chantier
titanesque dit le ministre bâtit sur la
décentralisation et la création de santé
Québec une nouvelle agence qui aurait
demandé de gérer le fonctionnement de la
presque totalité du système une
quarantaine de groupes sont attendus en
commission parlementaire qui amorcer ses
travaux la semaine dernière
ce que je vous propose c'est de dire
profiter d'autres projets de loi pour
ramener l'imputabilité soit au moins sur
les résultats très clair au niveau local
plutôt que au tracteur
[Musique]
mais je faisais allusion tout à l'heure
dans la présentation le troisième lien a
pris beaucoup de place c'est difficile
de pas vous poser la question est-ce que
c'est la la première grosse crise de
confiance de votre à laquelle les
confronté votre gouvernement mais c'est
vrai qu'on a eu on a eu une crise assez
longue que j'appelle la pandémie pendant
trois ans et je pense que comme on a
réussi à passer à travers cette crise là
de la pandémie on va penser à travers
celle-là aussi mais il y a du pour
rétablir la confiance au lien de
confiance avec certains électeurs
de Québec c'est sûr que et
principalement sur la Rive-Sud je pense
je pense à la Bauche je pense à ça je
dis à rapalache c'est des gens qui
comptaient vraiment là-dessus c'est pour
ça que les députés s'il était engagés
moi commencez député de vie j'étais
d'accord avec le principe du troisième
lien quand je me suis présenté en 2012
maintenant
les Québécois nous font donc fait
confiance pour ceux je faisais le
parallèle avec la pandémie lorsque des
décisions difficiles à prendre on est
capable les prendre alors encore une
fois ici à la lumière des nouvelles
données on a pris une décision difficile
je pense que la confiance va être là
qu'après un certain temps après le
moment tout à fait normal de réaction
des gens vont comprendre qu'on a pris
dans les circonstances la meilleure
décision bon pendant qu'on parlait
beaucoup de 3e lien vous vous étiez en
commission parlementaire pour défendre
votre projet de loi sur la réforme de la
santé la création de santé Québec
qu'est-ce que le bilan faites-vous de
cette première semaine de danse très
content très content parce que c'est un
projet de loi vous le savez c'est
complexe c'est costaud et ce que j'ai
entendu après deux jours de consultation
dans une dizaine de présentation je
pense qu'au moins les gens qui sont
venus que ce soit les les usagers que ce
soit la Commissaire à la santé que ce
soit le commissaire au plaintes et
Jean-Luc sont très proches du terrain on
s'entend sur nos trois quatre grands
objectifs ça c'est la première bonne
nouvelle maintenant des gens vont nous
faire nous ont fait des suggestions des
fois on dit souvent le diable est dans
les détails j'ai écouté les par exemple
les deux groupes qui sont venus pour les
services aux usagers ils nous disaient
oui mais vous devriez aller un petit peu
plus loin pour comment vous écouter les
usagers dans les différents com je
voulais mettre en place très très ouvert
à ça mais sur le principe par exemple
prenons ce de la séparation des
opérations tout le monde est d'accord
que santé Québec c'est la bonne chose à
faire parce que c'est une recommandation
très claire de plusieurs experts donc
c'est très encourageant pour une
première semaine de
consultation il y a des gens Monsieur
Michel claire entre autres qui a parlé
pas de décentralisation mais de
déconcentration avez-vous l'impression
qu'on laisse suffisamment de place dans
votre modèle par exemple suffisamment
marge de manœuvre au gestionnaire que
vous allez placer dans les dans les
différentes institutions oui mais c'est
ça qui est intéressant là c'est que tout
le monde a un petit peu son approche de
dire dans la recette ce que je mets un
petit peu plus un petit peu plus de
délégation ou un petit peu petit service
comme une grosse recette mais on
s'entend qu'on veut faire le même gâteau
alors ça c'est déjà la bonne nouvelle
donc on s'entend tous qui doit y avoir
une plus grande avec les usagers ce qui
était pas le cas de la situation
actuelle mais à quel niveau on doit
aller quand il reste juste définir si on
mettra dans le projet de loi ou dans les
règlements c'est là que je dis que c'est
perfectible mais on s'entend sur
l'objectif d'une plus grande édition de
compte aux usagers
évidemment il y a la place que va
occuper le secteur privé il y a des
entreprises privées qui offrent un
certain nombre de services est-ce qu'il
y a des mécanismes ou est-ce que les
mécanismes devraient être améliorés pour
assurer une meilleure édition de compte
de ces organismes mais oui c'est un bel
exemple merci lorsqu'on parlait de en ce
moment nous on dit dans le réseau c'est
très clair qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un
CHSLD ou qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un
hôpital puis qu'on devrait faire la
reddition de compte aux usagers c'est
clair par contre maintenant on dit un
établissement privé comme un groupe de
médecine familiale ou un mini hôpital ça
fait partie du nouveau périmètre de
santé Québec alors quand on va faire de
la reddition de compte mais il va
falloir qu'on soit capable de dire aux
citoyens locaux voici comment votre GMF
par exemple a donné les services qui
étaient supposés faire et c'est ça que
nous éliminent municipaux et c'est ça
que Monsieur claire nous demandait alors
on est très à l'aise avec ça parce que
c'est pas juste les établissements
publics mais c'est les établissements
privés qui reçoivent de l'argent du
gouvernement qui doivent être redevables
de du niveau de service du niveau de
qualité de service qu'il donne aux
citoyens par rapport une fois on
s'entend là-dessus l'autre élément dont
on n'a pas parlé cette semaine on a
parlé un peu mais ça a été aussi éclipsé
par le troisième lait les agences de
placement pour les infirmières ça c'est
terminé je vais faire adopter le projet
de loi c'est fini par contre vous dites
ça va prendre on va faire à terme dans
trois ans et il va y avoir des
exceptions il y a des gens qui disent ah
ben là s'il y a des exceptions dans le
réglementaire on ouvre la porte à plein
d'exception puis utilisation quand même
de ces ressources là premièrement je
voudrais prenons la Bonne Nouvelle on
sait entendu à l'unanimité avec
l'opposition ce projet de loi-là qui
aurait pu être très contesté ça c'est
une très bonne nouvelle deuxièmement on
s'est entendu que dans la grande région
de Montréal par exemple ou plus tard à
la fin 2024 il n'y a pour plus avoir
l'utilisation d'agence et quand on dit
qu'il peut y avoir une exception c'est
dans des cas très exceptionnels où il y
aurait un bris de service où on devrait
peut-être retarder l'application de un
mois ou deux c'est de ça dans ton cas
donc l'exception elle va être très
minimale mais troisièmement ce qui est
important c'est qu'on s'est entendu tout
de suite c'est à dire le moment que le
règlement va être déposé dans quelques
semaines que des pénalités pour ceux qui
ne respecteront pas les tarifs maximum
et ça c'est une grosse différence ça
c'est pas la fin 2024 c'est tout de
suite alors donc on en train de mettre
en place des mécanismes pourraient très
clair avec les joueurs on a besoin de
vous à court terme mais à moyen puis à
long terme c'est fini et pendant que
madame Lebel négocie des meilleurs
conditions dans la santé dans l'air la
fonction publique avec nos employés de
santé on dit aux gens mais revenez chez
nous parce que vous allez revenir à des
meilleurs conditions mais les agences
sont exclus à moyen puis long terme
parce que vous à terme c'est ça vous
voulez récupérer ces ressources là puis
les ramener en giron public c'est ça
tout à fait mais je veux aussi profiter
des négociations pour envoyer un message
très clair c'est ce que le truc madame
Lebel travaille qu'on est capable
d'avoir nous aussi d'aussi bonnes
conditions que dans les agences à savoir
la flexibilité dans les horaires des
horaires différenciés pour ceux qui ont
des horaires défavorables tout ce qui
est fait que plusieurs infirmières ont
décidé de quitter le réseau public pour
aller dans des moi je vais amener ces
conditions là dans le public et c'est ça
qui vont faire non seulement il y aura
l'empêchement d'aller dans une agence
privée mais il y aura aussi l'intérêt ce
qu'on veut que ça soit par choix que les
gens viennent travailler avec moi là les
audiences ont commencé les études ont
commencé de la semaine dernière pour
faire une pause pour l'étude des crédits
ça va se poursuivre après faites-vous
toujours confiance de pouvoir faire
adopter ça d'ici la fin du mois de juin
mais moi je vous moi c'est tellement
important ce que je dis puis je l'ai dit
c'est pas tellement quand est-ce qu'on
va finir mais avec quoi on va terminer
alors là en ce moment on continue nos
consultations avec une trentaine de
groupes après ça on va faire l'article
par article on verra où on est rendu le
9 juin s'il faut extensionner en
extensionnera je vous dis juste que pour
moi c'est important qu'on le fasse
correctement parce qu'on aime pas la
chance de marquer notre coup cette
fois-là
merci d'avoir été des nôtres
au plaisir monsieur Thibault à bientôt
merci